we're told the graph of y is equal to
log base 2 of x is shown below and i say
graph y is equal to 2 log base 2 of
negative x minus 3. so pause this video
and have a go at it and the way to think
about it is is that this second equation
that we want to graph is really based on
this first equation through a series of
transformations so encourage you to take
some graph paper out and sketch how
those transformations would affect our
original graph to get to where we need
to go
all right now let's do this together so
what we already have graphed i'll just
write it in purple is y is equal to log
base 2 of x
now the difference between what i just
wrote in purple and where we want to go
is
in the first case we don't multiply
anything times our log base 2 of x while
in our end goal we multiply by 2.
in our first situation we just have log
base 2 of x
while in here we have log base 2 of
negative x
minus 3. in fact we could even view that
as it's the negative of
x plus
3.
so what we could do is try to keep
changing this equation and that's going
to transform its graph until we get to
our goal
so maybe the first thing we might want
to do is let's replace our x with a
negative x so let's try to graph y is
equal to log
base 2 of negative x in other videos
we've talked about what transformation
would go on there but we can intuit
through it as well
now whatever value y would have taken on
at a given x value so for example when x
equals 4 log base 2 of 4 is 2 now that
will happen at negative 4. so log base 2
of the negative of negative 4 well
that's still log base 2 of 4 so that's
still going to be 2.
and if you were to put in let's say a
whatever was happening at 1 before log
base 2 of 1 is 0 but now that's going to
happen at negative 1 because you take
the negative of negative 1 you're going
to get a 1 over here so log base 2 of 1
is
0.
and so similarly and when you had at x
equals 8 you got to 3 now that's going
to happen at x equals negative 8. we are
going to be at 3. and so the graph is
going to look something
something like what i am graphing right
over here
all right
fair enough
now the next thing we might want to do
is hey let's replace this x
with an x plus 3 because that'll get us
at least in terms of what we're taking
the log of pretty close to our original
equation so now let's think about y is
equal to log
base 2 of and actually i should put
parentheses in that previous one just so
it's clear
so log base 2 of
not just the negative of x but we're
going to replace x with x
plus 3.
now what happens if you replace x with
an x plus 3 or you could even view x
plus 3 is the same thing as x minus
negative 3
well we've seen in multiple examples
that when you replace x with an x plus 3
that will shift your entire graph 3 to
the left
so
this shifts
shifts
3 to the left
if it was an x minus 3 in here you would
shift 3 to the right so how do we shift
3 to the left
well
when the points where we used to hit 0
are now going to happen 3 to the left of
that so we used to hit it at negative at
x equals negative 1 now it's going to
happen at x equals negative 4. the point
at which y is equal to 2 instead of
happening at x equals negative 4 is not
going to happen 3 to the left of that
which is x equals negative 7. so it's
going to be
right over there
and so and the point at which the graph
goes down to infinity
that was happening as x approaches 0.
now that's going to happen as x
approaches 3 to the left of that as x
approaches negative 3. so i could draw a
little dotted line
right over here to show that as x
approaches that our graph is going to
approach zero so our graph's going to
look something
something like
like
this
like this
and this is all hand drawn so it's not
perfectly drawn but we're awfully close
now to get from where we are to our goal
we just have to multiply the right hand
side by two so now let's graph
y
not two let's graph y is equal to two
log base 2 of negative of x
plus 3 which is the exact same goal as
we had before i've just factored out the
negative to help with our
transformations so all that means is
whatever y value we're taking on at a
given x you're not going to take on
twice that y value so where you were
zero you're still going to be zero but
where you were two you're now going to
be equal to four and so the graph is
going to look something
something
like
what i am drawing
right now
and we're done that's our sketch of the
graph of
all of this business and once again if
you're doing it on khan academy there
would be a choice that looks like this
and you would hopefully pick that one